what's up [ __ ] here agree in
the hizzy be lazy on the instinct
yo instant yo I'm really sick right now
but Tony's here so many of you guys have
requested destiny to rally the truth I
haven't played destiny so what I do and
I haven't played a game is I bring on
someone who has played the game to make
this video a little more worth your
while
even though you'll still hate me for
being a part of the video if I mean just
because you know I can she drink Sonya
better Ali boshy I've seen destiny 2
trailer guns may be dumb but we are we
just hope look around honey a gathering
of noble guardians new ones oh ok
there's enough you're a bunch of dirty
miss thing but you're all this letter
you'll have to do our homework attention
I would think 450 in response oh yeah it
kept coming do I get fired not alive is
Magnus despite the sacrifice of many
brave of me we lost everything the tower
the city our home so everything is gone
your stuff I stopped most importantly my
stuff then you know rocket record is
made is scary or kill when Jay Gould I
know you look to me and cons of hell but
this is not my battle alone which means
if I don't see you out there
I'll tell you myself it is God to avenge
this injustice well that is the beauty
of all God is worst case scenario you
die but who knows maybe he won't
so I ask you that game kiss me already
guys that that was inspiring also there
will be a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the moon
Democratic leader early access hey man
my way that I didn't played I always
play like online like someone's with you
and a couple times with the day and all
right what was that character in in the
first one the funny one yeah like he's a
funny [ __ ] that I would remember
them having something like him talking
like damage and other trailers or
anything except so this was like the
first time seeing them use that
character like that yeah just funny dude
like whenever you have to go up and talk
to him for certain things games really
do point comes to the gameplay because
it has like a Call of Duty style mixed
with like Caleb I was just say this game
is gonna come out really good because
they kept making DLCs for the last one
and really like making the the first
destiny go for a long time where you're
the kept people still playing it made a
lot of new adjustments added a lot of
new things while they were doing all
that I can't imagine they were saving
all the good stuff for this it's just a
great game it's just sometimes when you
ask if you just plain and constantly
like some people will when you get into
the groups of friends to play it oh man
me just like tan we're doing same
missions again I think they're going to
come back with some a lot of great raids
a lot of great upgrades guns I hope they
come up with just different abilities
different characters selections they've
been making a lot of great updates for
the game since its came out I think
they're even like launching one right
now as like one of the last ones before
destiny to comes out so it's really a
team-based game like you always want to
just like be legal player for the story
that is really just play for the all I
mean like the story is just basically
you ranking up so you're having to play
like a lot of the beginning missions but
then once you get to like the highest
rankings and stuff by that time you're
just trying to get really great guns
just to go into a different kind of
raids and graves are always great to go
through because you get a group of six
people and you got to do a lot of
different obstacles to get to like the
very end all around a very good strikes
team-based game where you just have to
rely on a lot of people giving you
information so and if you're just barely
into it just like seller dude come on
man listen up the [ __ ] you do it so I
would be that person most of the time
it's like come on ones last night
players like put two weeks ago what
happened twenty things happened while
you were gone for those two weeks what
is wrong with you - Emma no game play I
want to see what's going on I really
like I mean if they keep moving on with
this like trailers like this for destiny
they're going to do the same thing that
they did with Halo or they just like
make a bunch of offset videos and a
bunch of because I mean that looks
pretty funny right there and I didn't
use really great graphics oh yeah I like
the character I just want to see a movie
about the characters it was making the
funny jokes I mean that could be the off
branch it just just like halo I could
always make a little like side piece of
videos or live-action videos so there
you go you see some of that hey guys
Terry is tree Z on Instagram follow her
there and I need a I need to go to the
bathroom alright everything I said on
this breaks bad she does this give you
talk about